il a fallu que ce soit lui elle delphine
qui viennent qui m'invite
aujourd'hui vous êtes mans contre
improbable bonsoir par ou devrais je
commençais les rencontres improbables
ont toujours guidé ma vie un chemin voir
plusieurs chemins et je me suis demandé
et j'ai compris qu'elle avait souvent
joué le premier rôle
alors je vous dirai peut-être quelque
chose qui est un sentier tout à fait
battue nous sommes tous des noms d'une
rencontre improbable un seul
spermatozoïde parmi des millions qui
choisit ou ceux choisis pour féconder
une bulle et il y à là certainement le
premier des hasards improbable
ensuite un hasard improbable mon père
1944 américain arrive en angleterre pour
préparer les barges de débarquement
mon père ce héros mamère tourangelle mon
père à l'été arrive à paris il se rend
compte dans une soirée agitée par des
américains blancs waterside il repart
aux états unis elle rejoint ils se
marient sur un trottoir de new york chez
un antiquaire
bref il était tout à fait improbable
qu'ils se rencontrent et je suis né aux
états unis de cette rencontre improbable
qui a peut-être été un des attendus qui
a guidé ma vie
rencontre improbable mon mari je reviens
de tunis j'avais passé et quelques temps
avec mon directeur de thèse
un siège vide sur tunisair un homme
pressé il s'assoit me raconte sa vie mme
donne sa carte de visite
je la perds un an après j'avais quelques
recherches s'affairent sur l'afrique
je me souviens qu'il était directeur à
la cegos je l'appelle difficile d'avoir
un rendez vous il m'invite à venir boire
quelque chose chez lui je ne suis jamais
repartie
cette histoire a été mon destin et nous
nous sommes mariés chez un antiquaire en
virginie aux états unis
improbable la politique
le maire de ramatuelle avait dit à mon
mari vient donc au conseil municipal non
dit il je suis très occupé demande à ma
femme je suis élu en eau 12 ans je
croise dominique strauss kahn il fascine
par son intelligence par sa vision
économique
contre toute attente ils me proposent en
1991 de le rejoindre à son cabinet je
créerai pour lui avec mes meilleures
amies du ministère de l'industrie
le cercle de l'industrie qui deviendra
le cercle des grands patrons
bref ce n'est pas qu'est-ce qui m'a
guidé la 15 ans directeur à la cegos
alors directeur dans sa cabine et d'une
grande compagnie aérienne rien
j'aurais pu être happé par la politique
qui me fascine qui me passionne car je
pense que la politique au sens propre la
science de la cité quelque chose qui
nous est indispensable quand elle est
bien fait alors un soir à ramatuelle
je reçois un coup de fil jean claude
brialy à l'appareil
il était connu je ne sais pas pourquoi
ils m'appellent je cherche une petite
maison pourquoi avons nous passer de ce
rang semble au téléphone il me donne
rendez vous à paris m'a vite à des
jeunes et d'ailleurs j'ai payé
l'addition et ensuite il me dit je lui
dis j'ai un rêve faire un festival en
hommage à gérard philipe à ramatuelle
vous avez un théâtre non vous avez de
l'argent
non vous êtes folle oui je suis folle et
nous avons fait ensemble ce rêve de fou
il est venu à ramatuelle il emballe le
conseil municipal nous sortons nous
trouvons un lieu derrière les filles et
des amoureux très symbolique et le
théâtre antique un théâtre antique a été
construit en 27 jours et 27 nuit seule
la mort a interrompu cette relation que
je n'oublie pas et qui au fond de moi
maintenant avec michel boujenah nous
fêterons ce 31e anniversaire
qu'est-ce qui m'a guidé à faire cela je
ne sais pas peut-être que j'étais petit
j'étais en classe avec la petite fille
de marcel aymé et je me souviens
toujours utiliser l'orthographe est
l'apanage des cons et nous a écrit une
petite pièce de théâtre qui s'appelle et
fils ou pour vous servir
est ce que le mot servir a fait que j'ai
eu envie de servir dans ma vie peut-être
et puis le théâtre s est quelque chose
de tout à fait extraordinaire le terrain
si l'entreprise l'entreprise c'est la
politique
nous vivons en permanence la réalité de
ces choses les personnages il y à tous
ceux des célimène des don juan des
hôtels l'eau les caractères de la
bruyère tous à nous et qui nous occupe
et toutes ces choses et sont un éternel
reconnaissent mme recommencement le
théâtre est c'est la vie c'est peut-être
la vraie vie une autre rencontre
inespérée celle là je réalise un
événement au carrousel du louvre en 1999
sur des portraits des prix nobel de la
paix qui fait exploser un peu partout
dans le monde une seule personne était
toujours assignée à résidence
exact sushis comment pouvais je la
rencontre et jamais je ne savais pas et
puis en 2012
elle vient à paris nous organisons un
dîner autour d'un psaume sushis avec 50
femmes françaises dirigeante et à la fin
de ce dîner
nous rêvons de faire un forum en
birmanie pourquoi je suis alors chez
publicis est toujours directeur général
de human ce forum est cette femme
exemplaire fascinante mon ami tout à
l'heure silva disait quand elles rendent
quelque part tout s'arrête
j'ai fait un forum en birmanie à yang
yunhe et ensuite le président berman il
m'a demandé d'en faire un deuxième il ya
quelques semaines il ya quelques mois
am sam sushi c'est une rencontre
indélébile indestructible c'est un
magnétisme s'est elle est anglaise à
l'extérieur bouddhiste à l'intérieur
c'est quelqu'un qu'on n'oublie jamais et
dont on est fier d'être là me voilà ces
quelques rencontres que j'ai faites il y
en a beaucoup d'autres
quand je voyais défiler des photos de
sylvain j'aime visé mais mon dieu oui
simone veil a aussi conduit ma vie
quelque part
quelles leçons tirer de tout cela et
vous le dire parce que c'est à vous que
je les dis je ne suis ni énarque tu n'es
pas fixe mine j'ai fait des études de
lettres à chaque fois sur mon chemin
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un pas simplement
trois minutes
mais parfois une année deux années 10
ans 15 ans
mes équipes qui travaillent avec moi
j'ai appris tout seul à deux en fait
vous dire que il n'ya pas de hasard
prenez ce qui se passe faites le vôtre
vous connaissez ce petit dieu grec est
petite touffe de cheveux sur la tête
qu'il faut saisir quand l'instant passe
tout de suite c'est vous qui faites
votre destin c'est pas l'autre chaque
rencontre l'a peut-être tout à l'heure
dans la salle la personne qui est assise
à côté de vous vous allez peut-être
faire un bout de chemin avec elle
travailler avec elle
vivre avec elle l'important c'est de se
dire qu' il n'y a pas de hasard
il n'y a pas un destin fatal
c'est vous qui faites votre destin et si
je suis venu aujourd'hui pour tout cela
c'est pour vous dire que je suis une
femme banale
je ne suis pas riche j'ai fait des
choses dont j'ai fait ce que la vie m'a
donné ce que la vie m'a demandé de
saisir et ça il faut jamais l'oublier le
plus beau cadeau du monde c'est la vie
prenez votre destin en main faites
attention à l'autre
soyez humain je sais que c'est l'époque
du digital mais rien ne vaut un contact
avec l'autre l'autre et l'autre c'est
vous en faites donc voila vous dirais-je
un dernier mot dit m expect d une
expertise et je crois que c'est le chose
la plus essentielle dans la vie
merci vous êtes formidables